Merhabalar herkese hoş geldiniz
[Alkış]
Bence alkışlarımız devam etsin Çünkü bu
organizasyonu yapan
ekibe kocaman bir alkış rica edeceğim
sizden
arkadaşlar şahane bir işbaşı ağacınız
çok güzel bir topluluğu bir araya
getirdiniz ve gerçekten
geleceğimiz gençlere emanet bunu burada
bir kere daha çok kuvvetli bir şekilde
gösterdiniz
yapacağınızın gelecekteki yapacağınızın
teminatı Bunlar sizi buradan tekrardan
alkışlıyorum İyi ki varsınız
Ben Yasemin Bugün size annemin babamın
toprağın
mevsimlik işçilerin Hatay'ın çok
selamını getirdim
mevzular derin Biraz derin şeyleri
konuşacağız
8-9 yıldır bu alanın içerisinde elimden
geldiğince yol almaya çalışıyorum
öğrenmeye çalışıyorum Bir diğer görevim
Aslında ben de insanları bir araya
getirmeyi ve topluluklarla bir şeyler
yapmayı çok seviyorum ben bir köyde
doğdum arkadaşlar Erzincan'ın Ulu Çınar
köyünde doğdum Ve tabii ki köy yaşantısı
Aslında hepimiz şu anda bir kırsal şeyi
var hepimizde bir kırsala taşınma
kırsalın İyi olma hali içerisindeyiz ama
Köyde yaşamak İnanın ki o kadar da kolay
değil Çok tatlı Orada yaşamak orada
Büyümek orada özgürce yaşamak çok
keyifli ama her yerin belli başlığı
zorlukları var ben
yani yatılı köyde olduğumuz için okul
sıkıntıları belli başlı Tabii ki her
şeyin böyle sorunların da içine
doğuyorsunuz Aslında ve yatılı okudum
yatılı 3 sene boyunca yatılı bir yani
köyden uzak evden uzak kaç yaşındayım 10
yaşındayım 10 yaşından itibaren böyle
evden uzak bir hayatın içerisinde
kendinizle mücadele
etmeyi öğrendiğiniz bir hayatın
içerisinden geldim biraz buraları
anlatacağım Çünkü içinden geçtiğimiz
durumlar Neden ben buradayım Aslında
neden sivil alanın içerisindeyim ya da
neden sosyal faydayı Gülen iş yapıyorum
neden sahanın içerisindeyim ve neden bu
mücadelem aslında kendimle olan
kendimden Yola çıktığım için bugün
buradayım içinden geçtiğim yaşadığım
hikayeler beni buralara getirdi O yüzden
de böyle biraz geçmişi anlayıp
geleceğe selam veriyor olacağız Yatılı
okulda hiç unutmuyorum böyle gözünüze
hepimizin şeyinde vardır
hikayesinde küçük küçük size dokunan
sizde yer edinen şeyler
iki tane kardeş vardı
1 sınıfta yazılı okula gelmişlerdi
Gökmen ve Güler isimlerinde hiç
unutmuyorum sanırım 5 buçuk 6
yaşındaydılar ve ben Ortaokulda yatılı
okuldaydım
Gökmen ve Güler
yani konuşmayı doğru düzgün
bilmiyorlardı ama yatılı bir okulda
hayatlarını sürdürmeye çalışıyorlardı
tabi herkes anne oldu abla Oldu Kardeş
Oldu onlara ve bir şekilde birinci
sınıftan başlayıp 5 sınıfa kadar o
döngünün içerisinde yediler ben o döngü
o döngünün içerisinde onlarla Büyümek
yatılı bir okulda Büyümek çok fazla şey
katıyor insanı o yüzden çok şükür iyi ki
okuldaydım İyi ki okuldakiler bana çok
şey öğretti ve iyi ki orada paylaşarak
dokunarak yol alarak yaşamayı öğrendim
ki Bugün buradayım
Ondan sonraki hayatımız işte okul
evreleri hep köyde okul olmadığı için
dışarıda geçti lisede
Ortaokulda falan lisede İstanbul'a Düştü
Yolumuz Evet malumunuz buradayız ben ilk
İstanbul'a geldiğimde o kadar karışık
bir evrenin içerisine düştüm ki dedim ki
bir dakika ya burada insanlar nasıl
yaşıyorlar yani çok kalabalık her şey
çok karışık
ve
Yani o kadar tüketim bir yer ki
dedim ki bir dakika ya kimse burada
hikayenin arka tarafını görmüyor aslında
Kimse Kimin ne ürettiğini merak etmiyor
ve sadece Tüketimin üzerine kurulu bir
hayat var ve o gün dedim ki bir gün
herkes kendi köyüne gidecek İstanbul'a
gidecek bir köyümüz var tabii kalırsa
ondan sonra da zaten bunu dedikten sonra
okul üniversite yine işte dışarıda ve
İstanbul'da geçti birazcık yolun sivil
toplumla tanıştı Çünkü kendimi arıyordum
Aslında nasıl iyileşeceğimi nasıl
dokunacağımı neler yapacağımı
durmuyordum yerimde yani işte Okul
zamanında çok çeşitli yerlerde çalıştık
öğrencilik tabii ki ama başka şeyler
yapmalıydım başka yerler beni
çağırıyordu diyorlar ya Evet benim de
başka şeyler çağırıyordu ve yolumu
sokakla
çakıştım Bu arada arkada bir tane
fotoğrafımızın olması gerekiyor ama
benim burada bir basmam mı gerekiyor bir
yerlere
tersten başladık
Evet
Bu benim Çocukluğum arkadaşlar
üstümde ablamın ördüğü bir
yelek ve içinde bilmiyorum İstanbul'dan
gelen Muhtemelen kuzenlerimin bir
kıyafeti
hikaye Aslında tamamen bu yani ben
geçtiğim bütün yollar boyunca
Kendimi aradım
ve hikayenin içinde iken de hep işte
yolum sokakla
sokağa çıktı yolum sokakta çalıştım 4
yıl boyunca Niye ben buradayım niye
sorularına hep böyle şey ya evet fayda
işte bir şeyler yapıyoruz iyileşiyoruz
iyi geliyor şu anda burada olmak deyip
böyle soruları hep geçiştiriyordum ama
sonra 4 yıldan sonra kırsal kalkınma ile
ilgili çalışmalara başladım ve daha çok
daha da olma fırsatı yakaladım bir gün
bir projemiz var Ve sağ olsun mentörümüz
olan
mentörüm ve anlatıyorum böyle projeye ve
o da yurt dışında ilk defa tanışıyoruz
mentörlük edecek Ben projeyi anlatıyorum
o kadar heyecanlı anlatımlı anlatım
anlattım Dedi ki Yasemin Bir dakika dur
bir dakika proje çok güzel
her şey çok okey
sen deli misin dedi Senin derdin ne
ya seni buraya sürükleyen ne yapmak
istiyorsun Derdin ne ya Sen niye bunu
yapıyorsun
Ben böyle bir kaldım yani dedim
işte fayda sağlamaya çalışıyoruz
kendimizce Hayır dedi bu değil bu doğru
cevap bu değil dedi
ve ben orada aydınlanma gelir ya bir
aydınlanma yaşarız ya bir aydınlanma gel
dedim ki ya ben niye yapıyorum bunu
Yani derdimle sürekli koşuyorum sürekli
bir şeyler üretmeye çalışıyorum sürekli
bir yerdeyim
sonra durdum ve buraya gittim
Evet ben aslında doğduğum yerde
yaralarımla berelerimle öğrendiklerimle
eksikliklerimle kendime koşuyormuşum
bunu öğrenmeye başladıktan sonra Çünkü
yaptığımız iş sosyal fayda Bu alanın
içerisinde Herkes gelip size şunu
söylüyor ve oradaki kayma noktanız çok
böyle çok ince bir çizgidesiniz Çok
iyisiniz Harikasınız ne güzel işler
yapıyorsunuz Ondan sonra dur bir dakika
Hayır ben çok iyi değilim Ben mükemmel
değilim
ben sadece kendimi iyileştirmek için
çıktığım bu yolda elimden geldiğince
paylaşmaya öğrenmeye gayret ediyorum bu
cevabı verdikten sonra her şey böyle
yerli yerine oturmaya başladım
O yüzden de çıktığımız
yollar hep böyle bir
sancıyla
hep böyle ya hiçbir yol kolay değil
şimdi konuşmanın sonunda şeyle
bitireceğim arkadaşlar yol çok açık yola
çıkın diyeceğim ama o yollar çok
meşakkatli oluyor o yüzden de o
yolunuzdan asla ama asla
vazgeçmeyin Çünkü çok kıymetli şeyler
oluyor yola çıkınca
sonra bu ben bu cevapları verdikten
sonra zaten yerli yerine bir şeyler
oturuyor ve hikaye oradan başladı Ben
kendimi aramaya çıktım kırsala
Ve tabii ki kırsala çıktıktan sonra da
Kendimi buldum
arkadaşlar burada
yani çok çok tatlı gerçekten
mevsimlik işçilerle Yolumuz kesişti
Niğde
Niğde'de yaklaşık 4-5 senedir mevsimlik
işçilerle çalışıyoruz elimizden
geldiğince dokunmaya çalışıyoruz
Şimdi size yani Zaten iklim krizi ile
ilgili şirketlerle ilgili belirli
konuşmaları oldu o yüzden ben veriler
üzerine çok durmayacağım sağ olsun
hocalarım çok da güzel konuştu
biraz ben sahadan örnekler vermek
istiyorum Bugün sofranıza gelen şeyin ne
kadar farkındasınız
sofranıza gelen domatesin kıvırcığın
elmanın ne kadar farkındasınız ve ne
kadar sorguluyorsunuz ve bunun arka
tarafında Kimler var biliyor musunuz
ve hangi şartlarda bu Bunlar sofranıza
geliyor biliyor musunuz lütfen
sizden rica ediyorum Ben bugün buraya
gelip Benim konuşmamdan hiç bir şey
almadım
ama tek şey mevsimlik işçiler kalsın
kulağınızda
Çünkü siz bugün mevsimlik işçiye sahip
çıkmadığınız anda gelecekteki gıdanınıza
da sahip çıkamayacaksınız Gelecekte bir
gıda olmayacak diyeceğiniz
mevsimlik işçiler pandemi ile birlikte
daha çok hayatımıza girdim biz pandemi
zamanında bir yayın yaptık arkadaşlarla
ve ben orada dedim ki domatesin kilosunu
3-4 sene sonra 40 liraya 50 liraya
alacak alacağız dedim Daha yukarıya
çıkacak dedim herkesten böyle bir
domatesin kilosu nasıl bu kadar olur
Nasıl şöyle olur gibi
sonra çok geçmek zaten üstüne ve biz
domatesli kıvırcık en son 25 TL idi
galiba yanlış hatırlamıyorsam
o yüzden hikayelerimizin yani soframıza
gelen hayatımız içinde bu böyle arka
tarafındaki hikaye sorgulamadığımız anda
ve sahip çıkmadığımız anda orada
sıkıntıya düşüyoruz lütfen sofranıza
gelen her şeyi sorgulayın yediğiniz
giyindiğiniz sadece sofranıza gelen her
şey değil bugün üstünüzdeki kıyafetleri
de sorgulayın birazdan bu bunun
hikayesini de anlatıyor olacağım ama
şimdi birazcık
mevsimlik işçilere gitmek istiyorum Biz
orada ilk çalışmaya başladığımızda
şöyle şeylerle de karşılaştık sahada
daha önce sahaya gidilmiş ama sahanın
bir sürdürülebilirliği olmadığı için
işte giden dokunan bırakmış çıkmış
bırakmış bir şey yapmış ve çıkmış o
yüzden bir duvar var zaten kırsala
gittiğinizde de bunu göreceksiniz
Herkeste bir hayal kırıklığı ve bir şey
var Bir duvar var işte siz de
geleceksiniz ve bırakacaksınız Evet biz
de bazı yerlere gittik ve bırakmak
durumunda kaldık ama bırakmadığımız tek
yer mevsimlik işçiler oldu sanırım şu
anda Çünkü o hikayenin içerisine
girdiğinizde sizin bugün sofranıza gelen
gıdayı Getiren arkadaşlar o zincirin
üretim zincirinin
yüzde ellisini yüzde altmışı mevsimlik
işçiler üretim zincirinden çıktığı anda
biz bugün burada gıdaya erişemeyiz
arkadaşlar
yani ciddiyetin farkında mısınız
bilmiyorum ama
ve artık mevsimlik işçiler köylerde
gençler olmadığı için de sadece hani
ürün toplamakla kalmıyorlar aynı zamanda
ekiminde dikiminde onların bakımında da
çok büyük bir sorumlulukları var o
yüzden de o zincirden mevsimlik işçiler
çıktığında biz gerçekten gıdaya
erişimimiz olmayacak Biz gittik sahaya
biz böyle çok bir yandan böyle telaşlı
mutlu gözler meraklı gözler karşılıyor
heyecanlılar Ama hepsinin böyle bir tık
şeyinde
siz de gideceksiniz siz de gideceksiniz
Hani siz de bırakıp gideceksiniz kaygısı
vardı
ve ben onlara o gün bir söz verdim bir
projeyle dedi çünkü gittik oraya ben
dedim ki Bu proje
bitse de bizim cebimizde paramız olmasa
da biz buraya geleceğiz sizinle birlikte
top oynayacağız arkadaşlar
ve ondan sonra zaten çok
enteresan hikayeler gelişti Biz çadırlar
kurduk orada eğitimler başladı
Onların orada paylaşacağı bir şey yok
Çok fazla yani işte Zaten yalın ayak
çıplak ayak toprağın üzerindeler gidecek
bir tuvaletleri yok kaç dakikam kaldı
arkadaşlar
bitiriyorum harika Tamam o yüzden de ama
o paylaşım dediğimiz paylaşım ekonomisi
bugün çokça günümüzde olacak ve
konuşacağız İlerleyen zamanlarda her
derse geldiklerinde eğitmenlerimize
ellerinde patates ve Narla geldiler
Hocam bugün size neler getirdim deyip
böyle tatlı tatlı koşturdular orada
ellerinde olan tek şeyi paylaşıyorlar
bugün dönüp kendinize bakmanızı rica
edeceğim yaşadığımız bu tüketim
toplumunun içerisinde bir sürü şeyimiz
var Neyimizi paylaşıyoruz gönülden
evet teşekkürler Sağ olun Burada
çalışmıştık burada bir Es verip sizin
akşamınız gerekiyordu Bu konuşmanın
öncesinde
[Alkış]
Evet paylaşacak çok fazla bir şeyimiz
kalmıyor gittikçe Ama bu bir umutsuzluk
değil kesinlikle Biz çok güzel topraklar
üzerinde yaşıyoruz ve çok güzel
değerlere sahibiz O yüzden de paylaşacak
şeylerimizi şu an Hemen şurada
tuttuğumuzda o kadar çok çoğaltıyor
olacağız ki ama lütfen arkasından yani
yakasına yapışın
hayallerinizin de yani toprağınızın da
gıdanızın da sorgulayın bunları Çünkü
bugün siz buradan ses çıkarmadıkça
sorgulamadıkça artı bir olmadıkça o
Deniz Yıldızı hikayesi olmadıkça
çoğalmayacağız ve gidemeyeceğiz ve
çoğalamayacağız o zaman
onların size ihtiyacı var çok fazla
ihtiyacı var o yüzden lütfen onlara
sahip çıkarak Aslında kendinize sahip
çıkıyor olacaksınız
hikaye ilk yıl projemiz bitti Ve ondan
sonra ödenek çıkmadı Çünkü biz mevsimlik
işçilerin savunu olmaya başladık Çünkü
sahada müthiş şeyler görmeye başladık Ve
kimse bunun cevabını veremiyordu biz
hala gidiyoruz arkadaşlar verdiğimiz
sözü tuttuk ve oraya top oynamaya
gidiyoruz ve çocuklar büyüyor gözümün
önünde bir de mevsimlik işçilerin bunu
lütfen gelin konuşuruz daha detaylı ben
buraya girdim yine çıkamıyorum 9 tane
her ailenin 9 tane çocuk yapması
gerekiyor çünkü o 9 tane çocuk iş gücü
demek
yani tarlaya gitmiyorsa bile O kardeşine
bakıyor Annesi tarlaya gidiyor Ablası
tarlaya gidiyor bir şekilde orada böyle
enteresan bir Hiyerarşi kurulmuş
Biz şimdi gidiyoruz artık onlarla böyle
şey olduk işte Bizi gördüklerinde O
kadar tatlı o kadar samimi o kadar
candan gelen bir mutlulukla koşup
geliyorlar ki Çünkü bırakmadık
hayatta biraz böyle hayatta bizim
bırakıp bırakmamamızla ilgili
ilgileniyor
sizin ne kadar kurduğunuzu hayallerin
peşinden koşmanızla ilgileniyor ne kadar
mücadele ettiğinizle ilgileniyor bugün
oralarda yani 3-4 senedir aktif olarak
çalışıyoruz ve üreticilerle birlikte
tabii ki o kadar biyoçeşitlilik kaybı
çok fazla var şu anda zaten sabahtan
beri konuştuğumuz konulardan iklim krizi
en çok biyoçeşitliliği şu anda üretimi
çok fazla etkiliyor ve fiyatların
yansıması da yani görüyoruz içindeyiz şu
anda
insanlar yani oradaki yaşayan insanlar
da üreticiler de birçok şeyden habersiz
birçok şeyden haberli Mesela işte
tiktok'tan haberler
böyle kaldım nasıl geldi benim tiktokum
yok o zaman da TikTok daha yeni çıkmış
ya dedi sizi tiktok'tan ekleyelim Ben
her gün canlı yayın açıyorum buradan
takip edersiniz bizi dedim
şimdi ileri mi dönüşüyoruz geri mi
dönüşüyoruz
neresindeyiz bu hikaye şeyler Takip
ediliyor oradan o popüler dediğimiz
şeyler giriyor hayatımıza ama o
ürettikleri ürünün o biyoçeşitliliği
mesela Selçuk Amca şu anda Niğde'de
patates ekemiyor arkadaşlar
Çünkü kayıyor şu anda niye dedi ki
toprak verimliliğinden dolayı şu anda
Sivas'a doğru kayıyor Niğde'de başka
üretimler ortaya çıkıyor ama kimse bu
biyoçeşitliliğini farkında değil ve ne
yapacağını da bilmiyor üretici nasıl
davranacağını da bilmiyor o yüzden yine
burada bize çok fazla
iş düşüyor
TikTok takip etsin tabii ki tiktok'u ama
alacağı oradan öğrenciye şeyler de
farklılaşsın
iklimi de öğrensin çevreyi de öğrensin
sürdürülebilirliği de öğrensin bizim
Neyi
popülerleştirdiğimiz kıymetli Burada
birazcık O yüzden de yine dediğim gibi
burada bize çok fazla iş düşüyor Ve
yereldeki üreticiyi gıdayı unutmadan
hareket edeceğimiz zamanlar diliyorum ki
öyle de olacak
şöyle şuradan sonra
Bu benim evimi duvarında asılı
çocuklarla yaptığımız bir çalışma
görüyor musunuz bilmiyorum ama el
baskısı renkli renkli
bu aslında biziz şu anda buradaki resim
ve renkler bizi hepimiz farklı renkleriz
hepimiz farklı değerleriniz hepimiz
farklı düşüncelerdeyiz ama bu önemli
değil ne olduğumuz hangi renkte
olduğumuz hangi düşünce de olduğumuz biz
yine böyle bir araya geliyoruz ve bir
araya gelmek durumundayız
kendi geleceğimiz için bir araya gelmek
durumundayız kendi
varlığımız için yine burada kendimizden
başlıyor diyoruz ya şey Evet bizden
başlıyor her şey
ve bütün farklarla bütün renklerimizle
bütün değerlerimizle bir aradayız ve
böyle mücadele olacak ve biz bu
iklim
burada biraz şey davranacağım ama evet
bu gezegene kadınlar ve çocuklar
kurtaracak Çünkü bu iklim krizinin
krizinden en çok etkilenen kadınlar ve
çocuklar
O yüzden de lütfen lütfen lütfen
geleceğinize gıdanınıza
ikliminize ve kendinize sahip çıkın
Çünkü
çıkmazsınız görüyoruz günün sonunda da
ne olacağını ben buradan tekrardan ama
şimdi kişilere Hatay'a
ve gezegeni kurtaracak bütün kadınlara
çocuklara selam ediyorum Çok teşekkür
ederim dinlediğiniz için geldiğiniz için
[Alkış]
Belki bir öneriyle ayrılabilirim buradan
şimdi kıyafetimin
ileri mi dönüşüyoruz geri mi dönüşüyoruz
başlaydı Bu annemin yazması
annemin eteğim
benden büyük İkisi de gerçekten yani
benim yaşımdan büyük ve şu anda ben
bunları kullanabiliyorum
bizim dev daim Enstitüsü diye bir
oluşumumuz var döngüsel ekonomi ile
ilgili çalışmalar yürütüyoruz yel
değirmeninde Kadıköy'de bir gün yolunuz
düşerse gelin lütfen ve orada Diyoruz ki
her şey tasarımdan başlar
lütfen giyindiğiniz yediğiniz içtiğiniz
her şeye dikkat edin ve kendinize sahip
çıkın Bu kitap iyi tasarım döngüsü bunun
pdf'ini de bulabilirsiniz sahaflarda var
şu anda Belki oradan da bakabilirsiniz
Bu kitabı tasarımla ilgilenenler varsa
mutlaka okusun bir rehberi gibi bir şey
O yüzden de bunu da önerip iniyorum Çok
teşekkürler
[Alkış]